we're gonna go through some of the
basics of event sourcing but we're also
going to go through some of the history
of event sourcing and where it comes
from and then at the end what I want to
talk about is really where event
sourcing is going to be going where are
some of the interesting problems that
are still out there
and people are not really fully into yet
now I've been using this slide for
coming up on a decade because everything
that you need to know about event
sourcing you can learn by talking to an
accountant accounting is naturally event
sourced and literally every question
that you have if you go talk to an
accountant and you can convert it into
accounting words they can tell you how
to solve your problem whether we're
talking about versioning issues whether
we're talking about how to handle what
happens when you make a mistake all of
these things how to migrate an old
system to a new system they already know
how to do all of it because they do it
every day they are in a naturally event
sourced model what's interesting for me
is that it's not only accountants every
single mature industry that you look at
is naturally event sourced every one
finance law medical insurance when you
go to the doctor does he take a picture
of you and put it in the file and throw
away the old picture of you or does he
constantly keep appending things to the
end of your file it's a natural even
source model legal what happens if you
sign a contract and then a year later
you want to make a revision to the
contract
do you just go cross out a paragraph
than you and somebody else initial it or
do you add an addendum to the contract
and over a period of five years we may
end up with many addendums being put on
the end of a contract in order to figure
out what the contract currently says I
take the original contract and then I
apply the addendum zone
top of it you'd be amazed how many of
these systems are naturally event
sourced there's a lot of reasons for why
we may want to natural and why we may
want to events or something but there's
one really really important reason it
doesn't lose information how many of you
have an update or a delete statement in
your system today okay now keep your
hands up if you went and had a
conversation with the CEO about the
cost-benefit analysis of that
information how much does it actually
cost to store everything what does that
data going to be worth in the future as
a CTO I had one rule for my organization
we won't lose data because I have no
frickin clue how much it's worth
can you predict what your company is
going to ask you in two years about
today if you can't predict that then you
have no idea what the value of which
data actually is because it can change
over time which is more expensive to
store 10 gigabytes of information or
coke how much data can you fit in 10
gigabytes it's an awful lot of data that
you deleted that you could have just
kept but the thing is I have no idea how
to value this information so we kept
everything now keep in mind we're going
back to like 2005-2006 there are points
we're storing 100 gigabytes a day can
you imagine back then storing 100
gigabytes a day we've used big external
masses we'd store all this data on them
and you know what it took a really long
time to get it off why because when you
have 100 gigabytes a day and a hundred
megabit network to get data off like
took a weekend but I have it
what's interesting is you'll find that
an event source system is the only
system that will not lose data and I've
had people show me their sequel database
for an accounting system and then I went
and looked and there was one table
called transactions with a transaction
type and depending on the type they
would join off to another table to get
the data out this is still an event
source system it's just they're using a
different serialization format but no
matter what other system you pick your
going to lose some amount of information
and it's this losing of information that
can cause a huge amount of problems
let's take a look at this quintessential
piece of state and I've used these four
slides literally forever so here we have
a cart with n line items and some
shipping information associated with it
what we're looking at here is the
structure of this information we're
looking at the shape of the information
but this is not the only way of dealing
with this another way of dealing with
this is we could actually store some
events so here we have a cart created
three items adding and shipping
infirmity on added but at any given
point in time I can replay these five
events and I could build you this
correct I can take my five events play
them back in memory and hand you back a
piece of state but what we store are the
events there's a lot of benefits to
storing the events as opposed to storing
the state how many of you have written a
sequel migration script before it's fun
right
so one of the main benefits about having
events analog as events are much easier
to version than status and I refuse to
actually do a Big Bang release ever
again where I take the system down
upgrade it and then bring it back up I
will always do side by side releases why
because I'm scared I am not scared that
I'm going to take the system down try to
release it and then everything's gonna
break why cuz I'm gonna do a rollback
what really scares the crap out of me is
I'm going to take it down release it
bring it back up and everything's gonna
work for a week and then it breaks so
you guys are all writing sequel
migration scripts how many of you write
sequel migration scripts from the new
version back to the old version with
data having been written to the new
schema not nearly as many so I've always
joked on teams that I've worked with in
the past we can't with a good strategy
for this you had your choice you could
either wear the fireman hat or the
cowboy hat the hats were basically a
token to let people know that you were
working in production without fail
whenever you're working on a big problem
in production somebody will come up to
you and want to talk about the Christmas
party the Hat is basically to tell them
look I'm working in production right now
unless you have something material to my
issue go away but when we store events
events are much easier to work with
running side-by-side versions why
because we're actually taking our state
and deriving it off of our events could
I have two nodes running side by side
looking at the same events and having
different states that they perceive them
as this is one of the main benefits they
can look at it in completely different
ways even though they're sitting right
next to each other
don't have to worry about versioning
that state because the state is
transient in an event sir system all of
your state is transient
it may be persistent but it's still
transient at any given point in time I
can take any of my state in my entire
system and delete it because it's a
first level derivative off of my event
log this piece of state is a derivative
off of these events if I wanted to I can
go delete this piece of state because I
can replay it off of the events a second
time now this may be an expensive
operation depending on what your system
does how many events you have but you
can do it now it took me forever to find
this particular slide that I've been
using for all these years there's a big
problem inside of this slide accountants
don't erase stuff in the middle of their
journals this does not happen
okay maybe at Enron what if you took an
accounting class in university you might
have had a teacher who said something
along the lines of accountants use pens
not pencils you don't erase things in
the middle of your journal and as I
mentioned you can learn everything that
you need to know about events sourcing
by going off and talking with an
accountant and if you said to an
accountant what do you do if you make a
mistake they'd say well I have one of
two options so let's say I fat-finger
and I send you 10000 euros instead of
one thousand euros I could do what's
known as a partial reversal and I could
take nine thousand euros back from you
and give it to me
but accounts will tell you they normally
try to avoid doing this why imagine
you're an auditor reading the books okay
so it's ten thousand and nine thousand
you can do the calculation in your head
really quick and go I he intended to
send one thousand euros over but what if
they weren't perfect numbers
and what if there were five accounts
involved well you're gonna end up with
pen and paper trying to work out what
what I originally intended to do so what
they have a tendency of doing is they'll
do what's known as a full reversal in a
full reversal I'm going to take 10,000
back from you saying that was in mistake
and then I'm gonna give you 1,000 we
into the exact same thing an events or
system an events or system we might say
we have cart created three items added
one item removed and shipping and from a
Tiana did is this the same as cart
created two items added shipping
information at it well this is always a
fun question because you have some
people in the room going yes and some
going no and the answer is it depends
what perspective do you have on the data
if I have this perspective of the data
those two will come out and be the same
at the end correct what about a
different perspective what if I was
instead counting how many times an item
was removed then they would have very
different answers there's also a fun
game you can try playing in your own
system can you come up with two sets of
use cases that leave your database at
the same state when they're done so here
we had two sets of use cases that would
return us the same state when we looked
at it from this perspective if you can
find that in your system you just proved
something to yourself you're losing data
I'm gonna come back to the question how
did you decide the value of that data
that you're losing by definition if you
have two sets of use cases that come to
the same end point you have lost
something as not losing a data
it becomes more valuable when we start
looking at an example let's try this one
let's imagine that we were a big online
retailer so we've got all of our carts
and the business guy comes to us and
says I think that people that remove
items from their cart within five
minutes before they check out are more
likely to buy that item in the future it
makes sense correct
why do you remove an item five minutes
before you check out well you went and
looked and you saw all those books from
Amazon we're gonna be like 400 euros and
you thought my wife's gonna kill me if I
order that so you take two or three
three things out of your cart and then
you check out the rest so let's add the
feature to this stateful model so we're
gonna get a new one of these things
coming off the bottom which is going to
be called removed line items and when we
remove a line item we add it to the
removed line items and then we write a
report that looks at removed line items
and then doesn't nested sub-query to see
if you ended up going and buying this in
the future we release it to production
the user runs it and they see nothing we
have lost that information coming all
the way up until today when we started
tracking it let's try it in this model
so what we're gonna write is known as a
projection a projection is just a little
piece of code that goes over an event
stream and it produces a piece of state
in this case what we're gonna do is when
we see the item removed we're gonna take
the ID of the item and put it into our
state as well as the time that it was
removed we're then going to look for the
shipping information at it when we get
the shipping information added we're
going to basically look at the items
that we found and see if any of them
were within five minutes if they were
we're gonna mark that we're searching
for them in the future
found equals false if we found the guy
that bought this item in the future
we mark it as being true now what I have
not told you about projections is that a
projection must start on event number
zero and come all the way forward into
the log until it reaches now this may
take a weekend you may have a hundred
million events that needs to go over
gonna have a billion events that it
needs to go over but it's an
asynchronous operation so cuz all the
way through and then we write a report
on the state that put out business user
goes and runs his report and he sees all
of the information as if it's always
been there but we can actually do one
better I can tell the business user if
we had this report on July 17 2014
at 1402 in the afternoon this is what
that report would have said all I have
to do is to only play it forward in the
log to that point in time and I can do
this with any report in our system when
you give me a new report today I can
tell you what it would have told you at
any point in time during the entire
lifetime of our system that's pretty
cool and it's because everything has
gone back to being deterministic and
we're not losing information I don't
want to spend too much time talking
about the basics of event sourcing I
want to get more into things off in the
future and mistakes that people are
making
well there's one side case for event
sourcing that's very very interesting
how many of you have had to build a
secure system before so if you're
talking about secure systems there's one
particular attack vector that should
make you run away it's known as a super
user attack what you're being asked to
defend against is a rogue developer or
system
Minna straighter who is attacking your
system it is presumed they have super
user privileges
how do you defend against root it's
actually very common to run into this in
highly secure systems the one that I
dealt with we were doing gambling
systems and oddly we were a high-value
target
we're the ones deciding who to pay and
we actually ended up with a guy hacking
our system here's a good helper he
actually sat in the cubicle next to me
I'm gonna go through the story and
probably about two to three minutes but
the guy's name is Chris Horne and if you
if you put his name you'll you'll get to
Wikipedia pages and eventually you'll
actually get to a full hour-long HBO
special about this it's I believe the
show is called criminal masterminds
I've always joked but I never understood
about criminal masterminds as a show is
that they all get caught of course the
real criminal masterminds show wouldn't
be very interesting either it'd be like
and six million dollars went missing
from this bank in Toledo and no one has
any idea what happened we just know the
money's gone so what we were doing was
we we had a given pool type was called a
pick six
and because we were lots lots of tickets
in this and for some other varying
reasons we would keep them at the remote
tracks until the end of the fourth race
and then we would pick up the bets and
we'd ship them over at the end of the
fourth race but only the ones that were
still winners and it was Breeders Cup
day Breeders Cup is the second largest
racing day in America only behind the
Kentucky Derby so what Chris was doing
was he would go in and he would put in a
bet at a remote track one two three four
all and then what he would do is he
would edit the first four to be the
first four winners at the end of the
fourth race scan would happen to go this
ticket as a possible winner let's ship
it over and so it would get shipped over
and that that's a possible winner right
oh wait it has all all in the fifth and
six legs and the ended up getting caught
and he didn't get caught because he was
stupid he got caught because he's
unlucky which is what normally happens
with superuser attacks so he does all of
this bets get shipped everything's great
until a 30721 longshot wins in the fifth
and like a 14 to 1 longshot wins in the
6th he was the only winning ticket in
the world it was like a three million
dollar ticket so normally what's going
to end up happening in this case there's
gonna be 20 30 winners they're gonna be
worth one hundred hundred and fifty
grand each
mutual manager is gonna see this sign
off ship it but if you're the one
winning ticket in the world and it's a
three million dollar ticket you can be
damn sure they're gonna look into that
and this ticket was odd so of course you
know let's get that remote track on the
phone is there anything interesting
going on over there oh there's a
developer on the maintenance line that's
interesting oh the audit tape was
ejected that's interesting needless to
say we didn't end up having Chris in the
office on Monday morning but we had lots
of new friends from the FBI but we could
have gotten around this problem we could
have gotten around this problem by using
a worm drive and this is one nice thing
about events or system since events or
systems are append-only you can run them
on top of a worm drive worm drive is
write once read many so you can only
physically write to the disk once now
all of my current state is derived off
of my log my log is on right once media
becomes much much more difficult to
attack me at this point and this is not
a primary use case of event sourcing but
it's a really nice one if you happen to
run into the problem by the way if
you're dealing with a highly secure
system with auditors and you tell them
that your current state is all dry
off your audit log and your audit log is
on a worm Drive they'll like you a lot
it's basically the gold standard for
building these kinds of systems there's
some other really cool things that I can
do how many of you have had a bug in
your code before
actually a friend of mine a hottie
hottie Hariri when I went and looked he
had a picture the other day apparently
he had an aunt inside of his screen of
his laptop and it's like I just need to
make a joke about a bug but the worst
kinds of bugs are the ones that are
transient so the system gets into some
state where it's not behaving correctly
and then the system gets out of that
state and starts behaving again why
because they're very difficult to track
down one of the nice things about an
event search system is just like with
projections that we can go back to any
point in time my domain model is just
another projection I can bring it back
to any point in time by only replaying
the events up to that point in time so I
like to store my commands as a log and
then I can see that this command was
coming in at this point in time and was
getting a weird behavior it was getting
errors and I can basically bring it down
to a little app that I run that instead
of bringing up to the current version
will bring it up to the version it was
at the time that that command is being
run and then I can step through the
debugger and see what actually happened
my entire model can be brought back to
any point in time of the history of the
system as well
now conceptually we always think about
our event log from the beginning to the
end but sometimes you may run into a
problem what happens if I've got a
million events replaying a million
events is going to be slow so what we
can also do is we can actually go
backwards so now we start with event
number six we go to number five and then
we get what's known as a snapshot this
snapshot applies at event number four
and basically we can go forward from
there basically it's a memoization now
it's interesting for me is that over
time
event sourcing has been picked up by a
lot of object oriented developers what's
funny about it for me is that event
sourcing isn't object oriented at all
events sourcing as a functional model
how many of you have tried functional
programming before Wow a good number so
let me explain event sourcing in a
different way for you current state is a
left fold over previous behaviors
snapshots are memoization of the fold
okay that's it it's the entirety of
event sourcing if you actually go into a
functional language you'll have no need
for a framework whatsoever you need such
really deep concepts as left fold and
pattern match and functions and that
builds up your entire framework for you
normally what ends up happening as well
so we end up with an architecture that
looks like this so basically we're
storing off all of our events but our
events aren't really useful for querying
purposes I mean imagine I want to get a
list of customers with the first name of
Greg so I'm gonna replay over all of my
events in a MapReduce to get back all
the first names with Greg which is gonna
be faster that or a b-tree so chances
are I don't want to be doing all my
queries off of that instead I prefer to
have other models that I can query off
of as an example we might have a graph
database we might have an OLAP database
we might even have multiple of them it's
okay there's things outside of sequel
now how many of you have heard of these
before you know you're not cool if
you're not using these well with the
exception of one of them
but I'm gonna tell you a little secret
there is no best storage every database
on the planet sucks even events dorvan
store sucks too in fact when I see these
what I am reminded of is these how many
remember object databases if about 12
years ago I were to go to Q con London
there'd be lots of talks about these
these were going to take over the world
no one will ever use sequel ever again
in fact using an object database that
has no impedance mismatch with your
domain model so freaking cool about 10
times faster than using sequel and you
don't have to write all that crap
mapping stuff how many of you use an
object database today should have has
sound effect for crickets
so what happened I thought they were
gonna take over the world kind of like
these are gonna take over the world what
happened with object databases well
everything that they were actually
saying was true
they weren't ten times faster they had
no impedance mismatch it was actually
really cool and then you put your system
out in production and then it's not some
cheesy business guy comes up to you and
goes hey can I get a report of all of
our sales rolled up by postal code in
town and you go that means I need to
load up like two hundred thousand
objects in the memory and iterate over
them you seem to remember there was this
thing called like group by object
databases suck no they don't object
databases suck it OLAP and they suck
really really hard it'll happen they're
terrible for it in transaction
processing scenarios they're they're
they're reasonably good but for OLAP
they're terrible this is part of my
sequel is going to be popular forever
sequel is not amazing at anything but
it's not utter rubbish at anything
either you can always get your with your
thing to work whereas when we start
talking about other forms of databases
they tend to be very very good at one
thing but then really really bad at some
other things and one start learning is
that in most systems like this you don't
want to have a single model you want to
have multiple read models so you can
query off of why because using a single
model will introduce massive amounts of
accidental complexity to your problems
how many of her this startup so I don't
know how many people have actually read
into the history of them and so Twitter
at its core is a topic based pub/sub
correct so if I were going to implement
this you know what I would do I would
nor decades of research in the financial
industry on topic-based pub subs and I
would go take Ruby on Rails and MySQL as
my tool chain they got to the point they
had hundreds and hundreds of my sequel
nodes trying to keep up with their
workload and the entire thing was
nothing but accidental complexity they
replaced it with less than ten nodes
later by bringing in people that
actually had a background building out
topic-based pub subs the entire problem
that they had if you guys remember the
fail will it was all accidental
complexity nothing more and you'd be
amazed how many problems you can get
into where everything around you is
accidental complexity your 16-month
project could have been done in a day
with a different decision everything
around you is accidental complexity the
worst part about this is you normally
can't see it and recognize it when
you're inside of it because it feels
like real complexity to you let's try
another example with sequel so here we
have an ID a parent ID and some data how
many of you have built this before so
now we we go when we released this to
production and they come back and go
well this reports been running for 14
minutes and of course you go well it
works on my machine we should have use
docker so we could ship my machine
but what's the difference between your
machine and production number of rows in
the table you are running with like a
hundred they've got a hundred thousand
and you built a recursive query so you
guys are all good developers maybe you
came up with this idea so now you have
ID parent ID zero parent ID one parent
ID two up to the depth that you want to
allow on the tree because now I can do a
query where I can say where ID equals or
parent ie we do you want equals or
parent ID two equals or parent ID three
equals and then I can recur some memory
this is accidental complexity I worked
with a company in America they had
tables that looked like this and they
had to like half-million-dollar servers
trying to run queries across these so
they had one table which was people and
another table which was relationships
what are they trying to do while they're
trying to figure out if I can get a link
to him through other people that I know
based on certain relationship types
half-million-dollar servers running
these queries they have half a terabyte
of memory in them a raise of SSDs
they've been working on this project for
over a year trying to get good
performance out of this I don't even
want to know what their sequel server
licenses cost for this problem and so
I'm getting in and looking at I'm like
you know this looks familiar
let's install neo4j and graph database
because this is a graph my laptop
outperformed their $500,000 servers
we put it into production the next day
and basically we pissed off for the rest
of the week because we're supposed to
spend the whole week working on this
problem but this is common and when we
talk about this kind of levels of
accidental complexity it's not like I'm
gonna reduce your budget by 5% it's like
10 developers working for a year on
something versus half a day the wrong
kinds of models can cause a ridiculous
amount of accidental complexity and the
really awful thing is you don't see the
accidental complexity until somebody can
come and point it out
I have watch teams get in the weeds
trying to use JSON inside of Postgres
and then you show them that there's
other databases that actually support
Postgres JSON - and here's how they work
and they go oh well that's so much
easier or trying to use full-text
indexing inside of their database as
opposed to using something like leucine
or solar huge amounts of accidental
complexity come off of this and remember
that in these kinds of systems we can
have multiple models but this is one
place where a lot of people get screwed
up in events or systems and they like to
do this you know it wouldn't be a
PowerPoint presentation if there wasn't
a big square that said busts on at some
place so here what they're doing is
they're still using hibernate and
writing back to let's say a third normal
form database and then they're gonna
publish an event afterwards and this
causes a huge number of problems the
first problem has to do between this
publish and the third normal form
database because you're gonna need to do
this atomically somehow so a lot of
people go we'll bring in distributed
transactions and now you have two
problems
but there's other issues that come up
inside of this to be fair you can get
around the distributed transaction
problem by making your database into a
queue and this is what a lot of people
do they'll actually create a table named
queue and insert their events and as
part of the transaction into that table
and read them out asynchronously to
publish them onto the bus but there's a
more sinister problem in all of this
what happens when I put it in a new
model how do I get all the old events to
build out my model well I'm gonna need
like a control channel or something
there correct until I tell something on
the other side to publish them all to my
queue but when they publish them all to
my queue I don't want to publish to all
the queues just my queue and guess what
we just did we just broke both the rules
of pub/sub so the two major rules of
pub/sub is one producers should not know
who consumers are two consumers should
not know who producers are so when I
didn't have to when I have to send over
a message to the other side going hey
can you send me your history that means
I know who my producer is and on the
backend in order for my producer to send
them to just me he needs to know I am
his consumer and just think about the IT
ticketing system with this it'll be fun
but we run into a lot of problems here
when we try to replay models also what
happens with the old data coming over
and now I'm publishing new events do we
put them in with the old events do I do
I hold them all and give them at the end
once we're caught up again
of course if we're using an event source
system our event log we saw earlier it's
basically conceptualized as just an
appending file if you want to be a
consumer to me all you would need to
remember is what's the last event that
you processed we could do this with a
simple one method interface
give me the next n after X and then you
remember the last event that you
processed so he says to me give me the
next 5 after event number zero and I go
here's event one event two of them three
event four of at five he processes
locally and when he's done he puts in
his checkpoint I have processed event
number five now if he goes down and
comes back up he reads from his
checkpoint what's the last thing I've
processed event number five so he says
give me the next five after event number
five so I give it to him by the way how
many of you could do that concurrently
all of you right we wouldn't need to go
set up cues and RabbitMQ or or deal with
crazy things with a bus all of you would
be able to have your own subscriptions
now what happens if he wants to replay
well he deletes his local data and then
he goes I have no checkpoint anymore
give me the next five after I've never
seen an event before do I need to know
that he's doing a replay do we have any
coordination logic here if I had all of
you of subscribers any of you can replay
and do anything that you want on your
own we don't have to coordinate no IT
tickets and we don't need this concept
of a control channel by the way this is
also how blogs work a really common way
of interchanging between us would be an
RSS feed or an atom feed with events in
it
the atom protocol works in the exact
same way can you imagine if blogs worked
over RabbitMQ
so like you want to come read my blog
there's a link there and you say oh I'd
like to get you I'd like to subscribe so
what happens is that sends me an email
that you'd like to subscribe to my blog
so I go create you a cue and RabbitMQ
and I respond back here's a URI to your
cue and everything's good the posts are
coming but then you get a new laptop and
you say oh I need I want to do a replay
I want to get your old blog post locally
so just like what we were doing here
you're going to have to send me an email
to tell me to put all my old blog posts
into your queue so you can get them out
how many of you would use a blogging
system like this there are times when we
may prefer a consumer-driven
subscription and what we can end up with
is a really simple model where we're
just following events using this really
simple give me the next n after X and
when we bring up a new model
it's absolutely trivial it just starts
out without having a check point you can
replay at any point that you want
there's another benefit did we get out
of this architecture I can have multiple
of the same model I can have fifteen
instances of my OLAP model and we put a
load balancer in front of them load
balance two queries between the fifteen
different databases it's a very common
pattern now in terms of read models my
personal favorite read model is going to
be something like Ascot a star schema
all that model why because I don't like
writing reports I work mostly with
people and things like finance and
gambling and you know these people they
tend to be really good with Excel so I
give them a star schema database and I
let them connect to it with Excel and
they actually prefer this to me writing
them reports now when you start getting
a lot
these people you might want to have
multiple instances of this there's all
kinds of other cool reed models we can
have one question I like to ask people
is what information on this screen
changes depending which user it is
nothing
I know great read model then HTML on
disk I'm pretty sure we know how to
scale static HTML these days but the key
here is we must be able to replay this
information briefly I want to talk more
about the future of where we're going
because there's a lot of areas that are
very very interesting but a lot of
people haven't gone into them yet the
first one is functional programming too
many people are doing event sourcing and
object oriented languages try the
functional way of doing it it's so much
cleaner and to be fair you'll actually
understand event sourcing a lot better
as well the move from a way a lot of
people are dealing with data to event
sourcing is conceptually very much the
same move from object orientation to
functional where in event sourcing
everything is immutable and append-only
a lot of thinking is functional in its
nature next big thing multiple timelines
and you've all probably dealt with an
end temporal system before how many of
you have a bank account have you ever
noticed that you have two balances one
is called a ledger balance and the other
is called an available balance what
they're representing is that when I put
a transaction in I may not necessarily
be putting a transaction in that is
effective right now and the two
different balances represent two
different ways of looking at the same
time lines one is on when it came in the
other is on when it is effective
there's a lot of work going on with this
right now and trying to get into systems
that effectively deal with n temporal
data this is a huge problem for a lot of
financial companies trying to maintain n
versions of timelines and an events or
systems this is actually relatively easy
to do and I think we're going to see
more and more and more people focusing
on this problem because it exists in a
lot of industries and it's being solved
poorly in many of them the other place I
think we're gonna start seeing a lot
more of n sourcing is in clients how
many of you have tried to build an
occasionally connected client before a
client that works when you unplug the
network cable and start synchronizing
things in an append-only model it's far
simpler to deal with synchronization
than it is inside of let's say a model
where you're just mutating things in
fact many of these kinds of mobile apps
or now people are even doing it with
browser-based apps many of them become
trivial and I think we're gonna start
seeing a lot more people doing
client-side event sourcing now just to
summarize in future I think we're gonna
start seeing a lot more around multiple
timelines out of everything that I've
said today probably one of the most
important is that a single data model is
almost never gonna be appropriate for
your system almost never you're gonna
end up with two or three you may end up
with let's say something like a MongoDB
but then you also have a problem which
is a graph so you hang up with a graph
database for that problem now before you
go back and say Greg told us we should
have a different data model for every
report that's not what I'm saying
understand that for every one that you
bring in there's also an operational
cost if you bring MongoDB into your
organization somebody needs to know what
the hell it is how do I monitor
what Chad look for in logs how do I do
it back up what do I do when it randomly
loses my data somebody needs to know all
of this stuff and we need to understand
there's a trade-off operational cost
versus development cost and how simple
our system is going to be it's not that
you should just willy-nilly bring in all
these different models but you should
consider it understand that it's an
option if you have events that have been
stored it's relatively easy to bring in
new models it's delayed there we go
remember as well that picking the wrong
model can cause you a massive amount of
accidental complexity and again this is
this is not a 5% savings we're talking
about oftentimes it's like a ninety-nine
percent savings off of project costs and
if you don't believe me I want you to go
try to hire a Java developer to build
you a blog and you're gonna go to hire
them and they're gonna dig blog okay we
can do this so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna bring in we're gonna bring
in a spring and hibernate and you're
gonna be sitting there going WordPress
it's the same type of thing often times
we're talking 99 percent cost reductions
by choosing the right models and the
last thing is that event sourcing is
functional it's not object-oriented
trying to implement event sourcing in in
object-oriented languages tends to
obscure what's really actually happening
whereas if you try it in a functional
language it becomes very very clear what
is happening and it's explicit and
there's no magic going on like using
reflections or it's very very explicit
what actually happens and with that I
will thank you guys for coming out
I hope everyone
a good rest of the conference if people
have questions I will be around during
the rest of the conference and feel free
to come up and ask me questions and
again thanks
[Applause]